[Music]
hey gq my name is matt lays i am
an esthetician and the owner of the
men's grooming parlor here in chicago
today we're going to be talking about
various ways to remove a hair on the
torso area just in time for summer
the human body grows a ton of hair and
it's pretty much up to you
how much that you want to keep and how
much you want to get rid of it doesn't
have to be an all or nothing situation
you can pretty much just trim down to
whatever your comfort level is
and whatever you're doing for this
summer so like why would we remove our
body hair
first and foremost is actually just
comfort it's hot to have a full
chest full of hair another reason the
more hair you have
the more sweat in your body oils will
cling to that
hair which then turns into bo another
reason people might want to remove their
body hair is if you've got a ton of
chest hair
your shirt isn't going to really lay
very flat you're not going to get that
smooth uniform look that a t-shirt would
give
we're going to be covering everything
from the pecs you know the chest
abdomen always just a little bit below
the belly button
to make sure if you're reaching for
something on the high shelf a little
hairline doesn't come out of your pants
there
underarms the cap of the shoulder and
then the full back
as well
[Music]
there's a ton of different ways you can
remove the hair from your body
we've got waxing trimming shaving you
can go through and you can decide what
you think would work best for you
and your skin type with waxing you're
going to be the smoothest
the longest one of the greatest benefits
of waxing
is that we're removing the hair
completely by the root so it's going to
take about
two full weeks for that root to even
form underneath the skin
and then once the hair starts to grow
out it's just like this baby soft little
fine fuzz
[Music]
so first thing we're going to do is a
thin little layer of sesame oil
sesame oil is like your skin's own
natural oil this makes sure that the wax
floats on top of the skin what we're
going to be using
is a hard wax this kind of goes on
almost like silly putty and then it
firms up like plastic
on the skin this also grabs hairs that
grow in more than one direction
at a time aka like the chest
gonna get a little edge going here there
we go
and that's starting that and last little
bit
there we go oh and kenneth just you know
that was the worst
strip oh that one hurts the most so not
everyone is a perfect candidate for
waxing
if you're taking some certain
medications like accutane different
retinae your skin's gonna be really
really sensitive and dry
so much so that if we wax your skin
could rip off with the wax
and we don't want that i would say to
know if you're a good candidate for
waxing you pretty much want to go see a
professional
always best to leave waxing to the
professionals especially if you want it
done quickly easily
and without a lot of screaming what
we're gonna do next
is just another thin little layer of
that sesame oil and then a nice hot
towel that'll remove any last little bit
stickiness or residue this hot towel may
feel a little extra toasty
aftercare for the chest wax the chest is
one of the trickiest spots to wax so it
takes a little bit of extra after care
so number one just use dye free aroma
free detergent
and do a double rinse also one of those
shower gloves like a rough textured
shower glove to really get in there
scrub up using almost like an acne face
wash
as your body wash the last ingredient
there would be to follow up with
a ten skin ten skin's basically liquid
aspirin
or pure salicylic acid you're gonna need
all of these steps to ensure
a really good result after waxing
a second option for body hair removal is
trimming you know a lot of my clients
come to me
you know with like a big full hairy
chest they're hot they're sweaty it's
getting a lot of bacteria it's stinky
but they don't really want to be smooth
they don't want to look like they're in
a boy band or something
you can just trim the hair down you can
just thin it out so it's not quite so
bulky
so that your shirt will lay flat
trimming is probably the fastest
quickest easiest and lowest cost as well
tools you need for trimming number one
is your trimmers or what are in the
industry called edgers
i love the wall peanut i have used this
consistently i've tried all the new fun
gadgets and things and i always come
back
to this one you need a little brush
because you need to clean out those
trimmers about every two passes
if they keep getting gunked up with your
hair and you keep going you're not
really cutting anything so you got to
clear out the trimmers about every other
strip and then number three
most importantly you need some newspaper
you're going to want to lay newspaper
down so that all your trimming falls
onto that
then you just crumple it up and throw it
away
when starting to trim the chest we're
going to take those wall clippers
we're going to use the smallest guard
that comes with that you're going to
want to trim
in the direction the hair grows so the
chest grows in like this
then up like this and then down over the
pecs
and now the stomach grows in like this
a lot of my clients like they say oh no
i trimmed my chest once i hated it was
so itchy and prickly
so the reason it itches is because when
we have that hair shaft you cut it off
here
it's still pretty sharp and so these
sharp little hairs they poke through
your t-shirt
and so like when you're walking around
and your shirt's moving it's wiggling
each little hair like that
quick easy fix all you do is after you
trim
go ahead take the hottest shower that
you can stand getting like a little
exfoliating glove
and then scrub scrub scrub really really
exfoliate all the hairs that you just
trimmed
that heat will soften the hair the
exfoliation will kind of take that
blunted edge and kind of
dome it it almost like rounds it off so
it can't poke through the fabric of your
clothing
[Music]
for the back there's a ton of different
types of hair and that's gonna kind of
depend on how you're gonna remove that
like say you've got really kind of like
fine curly hair
that's gonna be perfect for waxing and
then i got some other clients where
they're gonna have about five or six
hairs growing out of each follicle
or active breakouts or back knee as
people call it you're definitely going
to choose something other than waxing in
that instance
i'll be demonstrating how to wax for the
full back and then how to shave your
back at home
as well this is a typical hair pattern
for back hair
it's basically coming from the outsides
in and then going down
and it kind of has this long downy
softness to it
super super easy to wax okay
just gonna do a little bit of sesame oil
and then basically we're gonna do one
good strip down the center then just
knock out each side
after that this is going to be called a
soft wax this is like what you see in tv
and movies this is the one that uses
that paper strip
because all this hair is growing in the
same direction
and just like the chest that one was the
worst
so it just gets easier from here on out
i always say
um the good thing about waxing pain is
it's really quick
by the time you say your favorite curse
word it's pretty much done
what i'm going to be doing next is
putting on 10 skin
it's going to almost feel like an
alcohol-based aftershave but it
dissipates in about five seconds or so
as we're looking at tj's skin he's the
perfect candidate for waxing unlike
blake
he's not the best candidate for waxing
because of that mild breakout
if you wax on top of that that's gonna
exacerbate that and make it a big
problem
back knee is super common a lot of
people get it i would recommend that we
shave with a blade
okay guys so for shaving the back the
easiest is to have a buddy do it for you
but we're not all so lucky to have a
buddy that wants to shave our back
so there's this invention real quick and
easy called the back blade honestly it's
like a giant razor blade
this can just go straight on your back
and then you pull up
this way and then another way to use it
is to grab it from the side and to pull
out
this way you're going to want to do this
if you want a completely smooth look
probably about once every 10 to 12 days
or so
you want there to be enough hair about a
quarter of an inch
so that the razor has something to grab
onto to remove
they do sell replacement blades but in
my experience i have found this blade
will last you
i don't know about a good 10 shaves or
so
once you're done shaving for the back
you're going to want to exfoliate
and the best way to do that after
shaving your back whenever you're drying
off with a towel
just do a really good floss it's mostly
going gonna be the shoulders that could
get irritable after shaving
so a good floss across the shoulders
drop it down good floss across the lower
back
and you're gonna be in a great spot
there i've got tons of clients they've
like shaved once and they're like oh man
it broke out like crazy i'll never do it
again
and that's a really quick easy fix a
couple things you want to keep in mind
use a brand new razor every single time
you shave also
it's the prep work first you just want
to make sure you take a nice hot shower
so that all that hair
is nice and softened up when you're
using a razor either on your face or on
your body
if you hear that like noise like two
pieces of sandpaper
rubbing against each other that just
means that the blade is going halfway in
and then snapping the hair the rest of
the way off
now you have this jagged irregular edge
and that can grow in any weird different
direction
usually back into the skin so if the
hair is nice and hot
and has some shaving medium it just
glides right through you don't hear
anything
we'll be going over how to trim for the
arms you know a lot of people will get
excessive forearm hair and around the
elbows and you get a ton of long hairs
you guys know this right at the back of
your arm
i always recommend just trimming for the
arms versus shaving or waxing
there's something that kind of happens
when the arms are completely hairless
there's many a clients where after i've
waxed their arms they're like oh yeah
dude you were right
like i feel like a dolphin now so for
trimming for the arms
like always you just want to make sure
you follow the direction of the hair
growth
so instead of kind of going up against
your arm think about going
over take the clippers nice and gentle
over
things can get a little tricky right
here so just going straight down here
works best and then just make sure
you're getting real good up around the
bicep there
you're just going to be using the wahl
peanut trimmers with that shortest scar
the 1 8
inch what trimming down the hair
for the arms can do just makes putting
on a sunscreen lotion
things like that a lot easier a lot of
guys get a lot of really thick
puffy hair right on the forearm so doing
this
technique where you just follow the
direction of the hair growth it just
knocks down a lot
of that bulk there
i'm going to be showing you how to trim
the underarms as well it's just a little
tricky because the hair grows in a
couple different directions
i think trimming's the best only because
shaving and waxing
the underarms like whenever you're at
rest the underarm folds in on itself so
that skin's
all pressed together it's like ripe for
ingrowns and irritation
just because as the hair grows in it's
all crunched together and then when you
add to that
perspiration add to that deodorants and
antiperspirant i always just think a
nice clean trim is the way to go for
underarms
you just want to follow the direction of
the hair growth half is going to grow up
and half is going to grow down
so to get a good stretch for the
underarm you're going to take your hand
put it in between your back or your
shoulder blades
go half up and then half down this
skin's
very very thin and tender so just be
really gentle you don't want to press
too hard
a couple passes and that's all you're
going to need
all right guys so you just trim the
underarms underarms can be a little bit
tricky because your arms are constantly
moving
and so what you're going to want to do
is take the hottest shower you can stand
really soften up that hair under there
and then use one of these shower gloves
to scrub it down
really really really exfoliate so that
it's not prickly
spiky or stabbing your underarms there
and it's going to be nice and easy
and clean to go
all right gq thanks so much for coming
on in today as you've seen with all
these tips and techniques
trimming and or shaving yourself at home
is really pretty simple and easy
all these techniques that i'm talking
about they are prevention
and cure so if you happen to break out
just keep up and stay diligent with your
exfoliation
and with that tense skin thanks so much
my name is matt lays
here at my shop the men's grooming
parlor located in andersonville
in chicago if you all do want to try out
that waxing come on and see me
okay it's mensgroomingparlor.com and
i'll see you soon